it seems an impossible task trying to
second-guess Game of Thrones author
george r martin or show creators David
Benioff and DB Weiss but people keep on
trying nonetheless we season six now off
to a story pack start it looks like
winter has finally come for our game of
thrones guessing game balam regardless
Thrones fans I'm Simon and this is your
news update of Ice and Fire Game of
Thrones season 6 is first episode aired
on sunday and HBO's already release
descriptions for the next two episodes
ewwe that episode threes description is
incredibly cryptic leaving us with more
questions than answers the second
episode in the season is titled home and
it sees the return of some characters we
haven't seen in a while Hodor Hodor it
is this sunday on may the first and this
is its description brand trains with the
three-eyed Raven in King's Landing Jamie
advises Tommen Tyrion demands good news
but has to make it his own at Castle
black the Nights Watch stands behind
thorne Ramsay Bolton proposes a plan and
Balon Greyjoy entertains other proposals
the third episode is called Oathbreaker
a little air in two weeks on May the 8th
the description for episode 3 is the
nearest meets her future brand meets the
past Tommen confront the high sparrow
are you trained to be no one Barris
finds an answer ramsey gets a gift
unless you have the power of green sight
it looks like you'll just have to wait
until Sunday to find out what's going to
happen have you got any ideas or fan
theories about the series let me know in
the comments below or come find me on
twitter i'm at the jagan or thanks for
watching and for all your entertainment
news keep it gamespot
you